foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and me Isabell Oak shot
so the Revenge of the ramonas after the
secret Summits the Cozy cross party
chats is there a Valentine's plot to
unravel the brexit divorce I'll ask one
of the eu's not so secret admirers
Amara's Lord hesseltine
and spy balloons stealth social media
apps and Investments worth hundreds of
billions in critical infrastructure is
it time to wake up to China's threat to
the West we'll debate that
plus the experimentary gender Clinic
where a thousand British children some
age just 10 years old were given
powerful puberty blocking drugs did
fears over the toxic trans debate cause
the horrific Tavistock scandal
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and
Isabelle oakshotts
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored and
tonight we have a bit of a Valentine's
special
the big question we're going to be
asking is after a very messy breakup
what exactly is a state of our
relationship with the EU it's four years
since we told Brussels we wanted a
divorce now what followed was pretty
typical of all big breakups a lot of
hurt a lot of anger and a lot of
expensive lawyers the big hope of course
was that when the nasty paperwork was
all finished it and that would take
another two years by the way for us to
get out we'd all be able to move on and
very soon we'd strike up new more
rewarding and exciting relationships
with other countries unfortunately it
seems some people are still nursing a
broken heart all they want to do is go
back to what many people who voted for
brexit feel was at best a very
dysfunctional relationship with Brussels
the question is are shadowy figures in
government and the Civil Service can
inspiring to rekindle the romance what's
that Rendezvous in ditchley park where
remainers like Peter mandelson and David
Lammy flirted with levers like Michael
Gove the beginning of an illicit Affair
that they hope will lead to something
more serious
well joining us now are former
conservative Minister Ann whitakam
talked to the contributor Paul Rhone
Adrian plus former deputy prime minister
down the line Lord hesseltine good
evening to you all Lord hesitine thank
you for joining us on Piers Morgan
uncensored we really appreciate it so
we've only just actually left the
trading relationship uh just over two
years ago it's the beginning of a a
long-term new relationship and yet
already it seems that some people are
trying to sort of bring us back ever
closer together
I know that was always your view Were
you invited to this conference
no
would you like to be so so you feel you
missed out
um but um in terms of where are we going
through I missed out at all
okay well in terms of where we are since
we left uh the trading relationship
we've got uh our trade with the EU is
actually up some 10 uh since the end of
the transition period it's up some 40
since the end of 2016. uh our foreign
direct Investments since uh 2016 uh is
about the highest of any uh European
nation uh well comparable so it seems to
me that people are sort of
um
they're essentially sort of talking down
bricks it's before actually it's been
given a chance to maximize the
opportunity
well if the figures that you've just
given were accurate why are people so
upset why is there a concern I mean you
just depicted a Triumph let me let me
just sort of help you a little you see
it's not the people like me did you see
today's Telegraph
brexit is dead
yes I did that was it obviously your
most fanatical supporters so that's
right how can your greatest supporters
allow this sort of adverse propaganda
which we published that was so that was
that was
that was an article by yeah
but the point is what she was concerned
about is that the establishment figures
let's let's start again what about this
one the bank of England
people a thousand pounds worse off the
Daily Telegraph it's not me it's your
friends
the reality is that our GDP growth so
the reality I've just told you what the
reality is I've just told you what the
reality is no the reality is the figures
you've been doing for six years how can
you dare to say that it's only two years
or four years the referendum
seven years ago and the people who were
in charge in the government of the day
Boris Johnson Leon Fox David Davis did
you think they knew what they were doing
two years before we had a general
election then we were told we'd get
brexit done why now are we still waiting
to know what that means I'll tell you
why because it meant a pack of Lies well
Lord hasseltine let me tell you why the
reason that we're in the position we are
is because laws remainers such as
yourself worked very very hard to thwart
brexit ever happening so you can recite
the many years since 2016.
perfectly well
you've had six years with your hands on
the levers of power we'd love to have
had six years people like me or simple
Sons
yeah many people say that we've got
bryno brexit in name only what's your
view of that where do you think we are
in terms of the journey and the
opportunity well I certainly think we're
not taking advantage of the
opportunities that are available to us
uh that is the first thing secondly
those opportunities are limited by the
agreement that was reached which was I
think brexit in name only but even so we
have got some freedoms that we could use
and we're not using them and that is why
people are so disappointed also of
course things have been conflated you
know we've got inflation largely as a
result of huge spending during covert
it's not just confined to Britain it's
in other countries as well but everybody
says Ah you know post-brexit therefore
on account of brexit and that is a
nonsense argument and I you know I I
mean with all due respect Lord hasn't
done you'll know I'm a huge admirer of
Lord hasseltine but he's just got this
one completely wrong we have not had six
years we've only been legal really out
for two I think that's a very valid
point
um and withdicam but do you think we
brexities and of course I was also a
very vocal supporter of brexit would we
do well to acknowledge that thus far it
hasn't been a Triumph we have to kind of
accept that bit it isn't that brexit
hasn't been a Triumph it's that how we
have handled brexit hasn't been a
Triumph that deal which we all warned
was flawed right from the start uh is at
the root of a great many of the problems
that we have brexit isn't to blame what
we are doing or rather what we are not
doing with brexit is to blame I can see
Paula
if you're going to do a job yes let's do
it properly yes and let's give it a fair
time yes in order to to show itself
absolutely
now
but you can't do that if the foundation
upon which you are working is false okay
and that premise was made on a lie it
was built on a lie we lied to those of
us in the East End we lied to those of
us up north we lied to the fishermen
sovereignundated by
um Turkish immigrants who wanted to come
and settle here was that true I think
it's true
of our borders and the truth is we've
had the highest immigration in the year
to June 22 ever because you didn't
regain control of the borders in the way
that we could have promised
that is not the way to win something
that's important
here I would like to ask him whether he
thinks that uh the voters were sold a
pack of Lies
is that yes what are you going to say to
that absolutely
you think absolutely that was the case
can I can I can I just can I just answer
the question please they were sold a
pack of Lies yes and the greatest
evidence of that is that six years later
when the brexiteers have been in charge
we have not seen any of the benefits
that we were told we would get and
that's because they were all fiction so
I think your six years is fictional you
can't justify that six years
forgive me I I let us be pedantic on
this one matter did the referendum take
place in 2016. yes but we didn't is that
six years Lord haselton
so look can we can we just just
agree will you please enter the
relationship will you please allow me to
answer the questions you've put to me in
2016 a government was formed in which
Boris Johnson David Davis and Liam Fox
the principal Advocates of brexit were
put in charge of the three most
important departments so they were there
six and a half years ago and Lord has
the time we left two years ago I'm going
to ask one final question to you Lord
House of time before we let you go yes
would you rejoice would you get on with
doing the job properly
I would get a job done properly by
rejoining the European Union so then
Lord has the time you're gonna you're
gonna negotiate the worst possible deal
with no leverage how ridiculous I
thought you were a successful
businessman
I am a successful businessman well then
you know that that would be a terrible
negotiation disaster
I love your interruptions you see you
won't let me answer the questions
because you can't bear the truth
let me tell you frankly you you know you
never listen that's your whole problem
you've just interrupt so that anyone who
talks something you don't like you try
to shout them down and I mean we we
dealt with the issue a few minutes ago
what was the motive of Boris Johnson's
electoral Victory get brexit done so why
hasn't it happened because it hasn't
used because the promises you see there
you are there you are there you are
interrupting again
it's a conversation not a monolith no
this is not a show this is not this is
this is a shouting match in which your
Technique is to shout down anyone you
disagree with you
I knew I knew when I came on this
program I would have to be behave in a
way that I deplore and to fight get a
word in edgeways because you think that
if you can censor what people are saying
by shutting them down you'll win the
Lord has the time to never win the
argument that way we're very grateful
for your time but the truth is you've
actually spoken more than anybody else
thank you very much
for your thoughts and by the way just to
clarify it's only two years since the
end
you're trying to get the last word I
know the truth came out too we remember
Paula Paul before we conclude this piece
Lord haseltine would rejoin tomorrow
would you rejoin tomorrow and can I
answer that in as long as long as you
can give me George Eustis told us
how things have
he finally admitted how things had gone
wrong and I have my friends and family
in the East End who can tell you how
it's gone wrong we have the fishermen
who can tell you how it's gone wrong we
have those up north we can have those
who enjoys
probably
yeah ah
next tonight our U.S China tension's
about to explode over spy balloons and
how scared should we be
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
please
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
well just before we move on to talk
about China I do think we need to just
catch up on that extraordinary debate
and interaction with Lord Hesse I mean
Lord hasselton I did expect him to you
know to be pretty Punchy he is after all
an Arts Ramona
we'll come to you in a minute because we
know you shared with you the reality is
that he keeps using the word lies yeah
but he couldn't admit that was Paula as
well both of them but but Lord has the
time couldn't admit that it was only two
years since the end of the trailer I
mean I think we've got to completely
nail this six years thing absolutely
because they keep on using it don't they
as if the more they say it the more true
it'll become hey I've got to tell you
hey Hazeltine nailed you too welcome
welcome to the show to Stanley Johnson
who we're going to talk now about China
yeah because we can be reasonably sure
that aliens were not indeed responsible
for the four unidentified flying objects
that were shot down in the last few days
over America China despite official
denials is of course suspected of
launching balloons to spy on our
American friends the first one traveled
across the U.S before being shot down on
the 4th of February off the coast of
South Carolina and a further three
objects were taken out in the last few
days a former head of MI6 today said the
West is under the the full press of
Chinese Espionage and next week world
leaders are gathering in Munich for a
major security conference and they'll be
connecting their mobile phones to you
guessed it telecom's infrastructure
provided by none other than Beijing
telecoms giant who are we well joining
us is the author campaigner in China fan
Stanley Johnson you may say that's fair
or unfair we'll come to that and
best-selling author Douglas Murray who's
joining us from New York
we will I think first of all we will
have to come to you Stanley so Keen to
get involved in the debate um
Stanley the bottom line is here but it's
simply the Chinese are spying on our
allies we've probably got to assume that
they are spying on us too are you now
embarrassed uh at your stance of being
so pro-chinese I'm not a talking bad
absolutely not look at the look at the
debate you just had with Lord hazeldine
here we are and I an isolated country
more or less losing our friends in
Europe we are not in a good shape as far
as Russia is incense so let's cozy up to
the Chinese can we really afford to you
know develop a hostile relationship with
China I think not now yours right am I a
sign of fun well in 1961 I tried to ride
a motorcycle from Oxford to be king we
go to the Chinese border I'm going to
finish that Journey off this summer I've
been in China I think I was the first EU
delegation to go to China in 1975 when
Ma was still in charge I've been there
lots of times one of my sons was
educated not Boris by the way not
one of my younger sons was educated in
singular University but you haven't
answered the question Stanley well we're
spying on them that is the nature
however I happen to believe that if the
Chinese say this is a meteorological you
know let's let's wait until they're
disproved
um we have satellites I'm not sure
Britain has satellites but the U.S
certainly has satellites we certainly
have all sides all sides of signs of
variations are we floating balloons over
Beijing well that's a pretty Antiquated
form I'd say it might be totally
appropriate for British technology to
have a few few balloons we probably will
the French could do with Mr blairier no
I think we the real strategy of the
whole thing is just at the moment when
Mr blink and Anthony blinken was about
to go to China to as well reset a
relationship which had been slightly
Nick and knocked off killed by Mrs
Pelosi's visit to Taiwan just for that
moment this unfortunate episode occurred
and the balloon floated over North
Carolina yeah let's move on that's my
body this seems an awful lot of
apologist waffle to me with apologies
from me for saying that to you I mean
you seem to be actively proud of uh
cozying up to Beijing
we're all closing up to
look at the trade figures which cozy up
to Beijing every day you just pointed
out all the things to be all the things
we use every day all the things which we
buy from China every day and by the way
in the world I do you very kindly I
think introduce me as an author or one
of the things that I do is write books
about the environment by campaign that's
a campaigning bot on the environment
without China a lot of the work we do on
the big environmental is we go down the
drain I'm sure that's true I'm not sure
they're being terribly helpful can I
just um let's just establish just how
close your relationship is with the
Chinese How often have you been in and
out of the Chinese Embassy here in
London well you could probably get some
some records of that I'm asking you the
question now okay okay first time was in
1961 when I was trying to get a visa to
go all right let's not go way back to
60.
is it 10 times 20 times oh not as not as
many as that but I have certainly been I
went I went to the Chinese Embassy had a
very good conversation with the then
Chinese Ambassador just in the run up to
covid and that I think was on
correctly right so you've been in and
out quite a few times well I think you
might say three or four times over the
period of time right and then I think is
a perfect legitimate you know
make any money at all from any companies
no I don't at all and they're very happy
one penny no not one penny not one penny
all right work as an only an honorary
capacity and but this is tremendously
important makes my point actually about
the whole thing about China and the
relationship and I work as an advisor
um to the Chinese
non-governmental organization called
Echo Forum Global which is working to
try and put in place a world Coastal
forum and that is crucially important
very worthy sounds all very worthy but
the reality the reality is
um
they're spying on us they haven't got
our best interests in heart let's bring
in Douglas Murray in New York Douglas
very good evening thanks for being with
us look how serious should we take this
threat Stanley Johnson has just said
it's sort of old technology this spying
balloon but geopolitically what's what's
really going on here and how should the
Western allies respond
well first of all we're learning on a
day-by-day basis more and more about
this and the American government has
been perhaps understandably Coy about
exactly what it is that's been going on
and what they've shot down and what
they've intercepted and what they've
indeed missed so far uh the balloon the
first caused attention was of course
described by the Communist Party of
China as simply being a weather balloon
that had gone astray a story which
absolutely nobody believed and you could
only spin if like the Communist Party
the rules China you're used to just
asserting things and not having to prove
them to anyone's satisfaction uh Beijing
tried this line nobody was convinced or
there have been people as I'm sorry to
hear Stanley Johnson just play this
trick himself I think it's quite a
disgraceful thing to do to say oh well
we spy on them they spy on us here's
here's just one of the many differences
uh Western satellite technologies have
indeed been used to look at for instance
the Concentration Camp Network operated
by the Chinese Communist Party in the
xinjiang province that isn't anything
like what the Chinese were trying to do
with America America Chinese were flying
uh balloons over for instance American
Atomic bases so this isn't anything like
parity as for the larger question of our
relationship with China nobody wants war
with China but we are in in an
increasingly dangerous standoff thanks
to the the behavior of Beijing just look
at what Stanley just mentioned happened
in last few years look at what happened
with covid China crashed to the entire
global economy by at the very most
benign explanation not telling the world
that an incredibly infectious
respiratory disease was coming out of
Wuhan right it did everything it could
to cover that over and you get up to
more recent times they have the goal to
threaten a Democrat a speaker of the
house Nancy Pelosi for asserting her
right to go to Taiwan this this comes
after years of threatening British
officials perhaps something we should
get into Douglas because anyone who
pretends that what we're dealing with
with the CCP is a sort of benign
operator can't possibly have their
Spectacles on uh Douglas Murray can I
ask are you on tick tock
no absolutely not understanding are you
on technology
do you think that we're naive about
um social media apps like Tick Tock
there have been some concerns expressed
that it's not all As It Seems with tick
tock is
Tick Tock I do
um Tick Tock I wrote the first piece in
the British press about this after
interviewing then Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo in his son several years ago
Tick Tock is a piece of Chinese malware
uh which is a data harvesting entity
among many other things it's not
permitted to be operated in China it is
used in the west to collect data from
young people in the west anybody
watching who has Tick Tock or whose
children have Tick Tock take it off your
phone let's you are not the user of the
product you are the product let's just
um we've just got a clip on Tick Tock
just uh let's just watch this
it always blows my mind when I look at
you know the number of people who use
tick tock I mean I'm one of them right
you know you use the sort of videos are
we being a bit Sophie get off it stop it
can we be naive are we I'm worried now
we are we are being naive
um so look you know Tick Tock gave
evidence to my committee where they said
that there was no way that individuals
working in China could get access to the
data of Britain's but what we've now
seen is that people working in China for
tick tock hacked into European data so
they could track down the source of a
journalist
uh Stanley I know you're you're itching
to come in here I mean you've actually
traveled out to the province haven't you
or you were intending to travel to the
province where the uyghur crimes have
taken place how I mean how are you
coming you're using words which you know
oh you don't think the treatment of the
uyghurs is Criminal no I'm not I'm not
getting into that um
Isabel the journey I'm going to do is
follow to re-follow the steps of Marco
Polo in China in the in the 13th century
and it's a bridge building exercise and
I want to make a point here because all
of you the people on the far right of
the conservative party excuse me I don't
think either of us are on the far right
even more right then what we're trying
to do I think is not whip up the
temperature on China that is not the
game is that what you'd say to the
uyghurs it is a big big mistake to whip
up the game and I'm certainly not going
to play that game so you I think I'm
there for bridge building that is the
point and so you're just going to
blinker yourself to uh the mistreatment
of the uighur Muslims you're just going
to ignore that because it's inconvenient
to you well hold on I don't I don't know
what I have what I'm going to see do I
know why I don't even research that you
haven't researched the human rights
abuses everything is there I read the
reports of the UN reporter I've you know
I I've read them and that is and you're
still comfortable okay well who is who
is not are you comfortable buying
Chinese food buying Chinese products
that's different to National Security
changes let's go back to to Douglas how
do you respond to Stanley Johnson sort
of
a view of the uyghurs that it's
irrelevant to the broader Heights
Stanley has his own Stanley Johnson has
his own game he's playing I'm not
entirely sure what it is but it's
obviously not an investative game we can
say that at the very least can't we I
mean you don't have to know exactly
what's happening in xinjiang although I
would if I were you uh you can just look
at what the ccp's done to our friends in
Hong Kong over the last decade just look
at what it's doing with its overflights
into territorials airspace of the
Taiwanese uh look at its assistance to
Moscow go back 10 years if Stanley
doesn't care about our allies like
America and its treatment by the CCP and
doesn't care about the Hong people of
Hong Kong doesn't care about the people
of xinjiang and so on perhaps you could
care about the way in which the Chinese
government has treated the government of
our own country 10 years ago the then
conservative Prime Minister David
Cameron had the goal to meet with the
Dalai Lama uh he met with uh with Nick
Clegg as well the Deputy Prime Minister
may I please finish my point because
it's very important it's better than the
waffle you're going to get from Stanley
um the the Prime Minister and Deputy
Prime Minister after having the goal to
meet the Dalai Lama were informed that
there would be no more trade
negotiations with Beijing they were they
were put in the freezer those
negotiations until there was a formal
apology by the British government which
at the next meeting with their Chinese
counterparts was pushed across the table
and the British diplomats were asked to
stand up read the apology and were told
we just wanted to know you meant it so
that's how the Chinese have treated us
for years anyone who at this point is
ignorant is willfully so indeed thank
you very much uh Douglas Murray finally
uh Stanley you boasted about one of your
sons being educated in China was all
this apology uh shared by your other son
Boris Johnson when he was a prime
minister did he share your attitudes
towards China no I can't speak for Boris
on this but I'm perfectly but perfectly
sure that he like any other sane person
at this moment does not want to get into
this bidding up war of legendary let's
really Drive China into a corner
this program is yeah we could spend a
lot of different I can see that you were
vexed by Hazeltine not at all your
position on China that's what we're
that's fine
thank you very much for coming in and
sharing that with us next tonight we'll
talk to a former patient who's suing the
NHS over gender reassignment surgery
that he says he didn't need
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back the controversial Clinic
that pushed teenagers into changing
their gender when they might actually
have been gay or had autism the
Tavistock in North London is set to
close this spring after an independent
review said it risked harming those in
its care now a new book sheds further
damning light on the clinic in time to
think the writer Hannah Barnes says that
Medics ignored the fact that a huge 97
of children who were looking to change
their sex were actually Autistic or
suffering from depression or other
mental health problems that might have
caused their unhappiness instead doctors
routinely referred under 16s for drugs
to block the onset of puberty with no
idea of the long-term effects kids as
young as three were sent to the clinic
and anyone who spoke out against it was
demonized well joining us now is
journalist and campaigner for sex-based
human rights Helen Joyce Richie Herron
who's preparing to sue an NHS trust
follow following his sex change and in
the studio Paul alone Adrian is still
with us to start with Helen can we go to
you please can you just set the scene
here because many people will not be
familiar with the details and the
extraordinary Scandal that's emerged
it really is a scandal completely
shocking it's been clear to anyone who
has paid attention for several years now
that evidence was not properly used at
this Clinic it wasn't run the way that
other NHS Services were ideology had
taken over rather than proper medical
practice and proper medical ethics and
evidence
but yet if you try to say something
about this you got called transphobic
and you for example people would say you
should lose your job so it's so kudos to
Hannah Barr and this wonderful
journalist that she managed to get this
book published she used fois she pushed
through she found a publishing deal when
Publishers tried to Blacklist her and
she's got this book out now and as I say
we've known for years that things
weren't right but now we've got chapter
and verse she's got it there in a book
with all the evidence amazing quotes
from former patients former clinicians
whistleblowers and now it is written in
black and twice that this was not done
properly children were not properly
cared for and Helen why has it taken so
long I mean when we look back at it you
look at the extraordinary growth in
numbers from something like 50 Children
a year being referred to thousands of
children being referred why did it take
so long I mean was it all about the
money the growth in revenue for the
trusting question
I'm sure that played a bit of a part but
I wouldn't say it was the main part
sadly this happens in medicine we see
medical scandals again and again and
what happens is that people who are
inside a particular Paradigm who have a
particular idea about how treatment
should work become completely obsessed
with that and they push it they don't
look for evidence they you know they
demonize people who say that hang on you
haven't got the evidence and
unfortunately on this occasion identity
politics got involved too so these
children were seen instead of being you
know ill children or unwell children who
needed help and had very complex
problems you mentioned autism you
mentioned that maybe they were going to
grow up gay so they face homophobia
there was child abuse depression
self-harm anorexia all sorts and instead
they were seen as trans children right
and that meant that they had to be just
Affirmed
you know absolutely shocking yeah well
I'd really like to bring in Richie
Herron here because I suppose when all
said and done what really matters is not
the politics of this but the actual
profound impact on patients and on
children impacts that would be lifelong
and Richie whilst you were not treated
at the Tavistock you have a very
powerful story to tell don't you from
your own experience of what can happen
when young people are as it were rather
rushed through this treatment they are
transitioned they're put on puberty
blockers they may have second thoughts
later can you tell us what happened to
you
yeah I found the Jeff gender affirmation
approach to be a little bit of a slope
that got steeper after every passing
appointment
um I am gay I had I still have severe
mental health issues one of them being
OCD which they knew about before me
going into the clinic and all these
issues were kind of explained away and
then when I eventually had the surgery
um I was told that the reason that I
regretted the surgery was because of
those mental health issues which before
weren't related so I was kind of like
gaslit a lot on the on the way there you
know and it felt very unfair and to me
one of the reasons why I want to raise
the alarm is it's terrible what's
happened to children and credit uh
Hannah Ellis um Hannah Bond sorry for
for a wonderful book yeah just by way of
background with your story am I correct
that you were born male then you thought
you wanted you wanted to transition to
female you went through pretty brutal
surgery and then was it how long a
period passed before you thought
actually maybe that was a terrible
mistake
oh the surgery itself as soon as I was
um conscious I knew it was a mistake
even before I knew it went well really
and then yeah after it after I realized
how bad it was it just got worse and
worse and then that brought into
question a lot of my whole transition
and why I individually wanted to
transition
um and it wasn't until like reality hit
me that I was able to really think about
the reasons why
um and it was just too little too late
I'm afraid for me so what what is your
situation now
um are you are you sort of at peace with
where you are or do you have more
surgery to do what's the next step for
you if there is one
I think the lesson learned in this is
that mental health problems can't be
solved with hormones and scalables and
I'm reluctant to touch another scalpel
unless it's to help fix what I currently
have
um for instance um about a undergo a
procedure that I'll have to have every
four or five years for a urethral
dilation because me urethra constantly
gets constricted which causes a lot of
issues pain and incontinence and a lot
of uh personal things that I want to get
too much and it will have yeah yeah of
course
um I mean Paula I think that Richie puts
it so powerfully there doesn't he you
know a lot of people's mental health
problems can't be fixed by hormones and
scalpels and the reality is that once
you've gone down the hormones and
scalpels root there is no turning back
and and he's so right and before we even
get to the difficult issue about gender
identity and we look at the issue of
mental health and in particular the
treatment of mental health issues with
children it is in a shocking State an
absolutely shocking State and when you
are a parent of a child who's suffering
with mental health you have very limited
options in terms of where you can turn
to to help for health and what seems to
have happened in relation to some of
these children particularly we know that
there's up to a thousand cases that are
going to be brought against the
Tavistock in relation to treatment that
was being received that it seems that
issues in relation to their mental
health just were not addressed and the
title gender identity was what was in
Focus where was the safeguarding of this
I mean I've been a governor with many of
us been governors of schools
safeguarding is absolutely four square
center of everything including as you
say mental health and yet safeguarding
seems here to have gone completely out
of the window for some of the most
vulnerable anxious
depressed children very often victims of
bullying
I cannot believe having been a governor
of a normal school how this could have
got through well ultimately remember the
treatment Pathways lie with your medic
with your treating clinician and that's
where that Duty and responsibility lies
and one of the things that I understand
from having read the interim report is
that they were just simply overwhelmed
with the amount of patients that were
being referred to them they simply
couldn't cope and the systems weren't in
place the processes weren't in place to
manage that overflow yeah well I think
it's important because we've been very
critical here just to give the Tavistock
and the Portman NHS trust a bit of a
right of reply they're the ones that run
the Tavistock center for the NHS and
they say that the gender identity
development service often known as gids
worked on a case-by-case basis with
every young person and their family
thoughtfully and holistically with no
expectation of what the right outcome
for them might be concerns relating to
Young people's well-being are taken
seriously and investigated so that's
their defense and Paul are you speaking
quite from the heart on this is this
something that you've come across in
your work as a family lawyer or just
something you've taken an interest
absolutely in terms of children who are
in the care system in terms of children
who whose parents are unable to agree on
where the child should live
um it's incredibly hard for that child
who unfortunately and suffers
emotionally and expresses that suffering
through their mental health and will
struggle with their mental health for
the parent being able to access help
it's practically non-existent if there's
what can we just bring in Richie before
we wrap up on this if we can bring
Richie back um if there was one thing
that you could change about the way uh
young people who go to go to clinicians
to seek their advice on these matters
are are treated what would you change
um I think it's not just a one single
issue I think of course I'm just looking
for a quick hit here
a quick hit
um I would say more information about
your background and motivations for
trauma a lot more work around trauma I
think would be helpful for a lot more
time because some a lot of patients are
saying actually they only needed a
couple of consultations before they were
prescribed this stuff
yeah
yeah more time maybe but I mean for
those who are uh who are like obsessed
as I was to go down and I I don't know
how much time would have helped but some
maybe if they're addressed the obsession
itself yeah that's a really interesting
point Richard thank you so much just
before we uh have a chat Helen can just
bring you in uh one last time I'm
concerned that when kids closes this is
these These are going to be pushed out
to Regional centers in the country and
that these these Horrors frankly will
continue
this worries me too at least with one
clinic at Jin's although it was a
terrible Clinic it was the focus of
everybody's attention and campaigners
could look in one place to see what was
going wrong we'll have to watch like
Hawks how these four Regional centers
are run and make sure that the
ideologues don't come back in indeed
thank you very much to all of you on
that today it's really quite disturbing
I mean I did think Richie made a an
important point about the obsession that
young people develop
um and you know the clinics themselves
are on a lot of pressure to come up with
a solution aren't they absolutely well
right on a lighter note yes it's
Valentine's Day the most romantic day of
the year here's my roses now for you
we'll be looking at who's been paying
the right price and who's been paying
through the nose for one of those red
red roses
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thanks
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
well coming up on the talk and energy
firm Sparks Fury for sending staff on an
all-expenses Maldives holiday as
Millions struggle to pay their bills
back at home and the cash-strapped
ministry of defense is under Fire for
spending 30 grand a year on biscuits and
would you give up your seat for a child
well mum one mum has shamed commuters on
Tick Tock for not doing that all of that
coming up at nine
welcome back well Paula is still with us
and Anne is back and Happy Valentine's
Day today Happy Valentine's Day to you
too thank you very much I was actually a
bit worried you were going to forget it
of course I wouldn't forget it how could
I forget it I mean I've spent a fortune
on roses I don't want to know how much
you spent while we're on the summer
while we're on the subject of money it
turns out that actually you can spend a
massive range you can go from five
pounds at Tesco's is that what you were
going to do no certainly not 14 pounds
at Morrisons at 15 pounds in Ms if you
go to Liverpool Street Station this is
just for red roses this is just for red
roses have a guess how many hundreds of
pounds at Liverpool Street station for a
dozen red roses three quid three quid
quid where's your generosity MP salary
in Dublin right Paula how much Liverpool
Street station for a dozen smart roses
Posh one Posh ones 150 pounds well
actually since I
I give you this Rose which was one of
the 12 that this gorgeous man gave me I
believe that he says it's a posterous I
mean I have no way of knowing
um this is a high-end Rose you can get
Supermarket versions which are I don't
think they're as good mine was not a
supermarket but it does seem that we are
a very romantic Nation last year despite
the cost of living crisis it turns out
that almost 1.4 billion pounds atom was
spent on Valentine's Day in the UK in
the UK alone that's a 15 increase on the
previous year we were you part of that
spending power I certainly wasn't part
of that spending power no and at that
quite honestly it hasn't even got any
sense I mean I'd cheerfully said that
see that I gave that what I was going to
say I cheerfully send it to give a
hofstats
maybe I need to do that well look
Richard's very romantic we know this
because he's even written a poem for
Valentine's Day oh wow oh come on yeah I
mean obviously we're going to recite
your poem spells go on oh yeah well I
put this on Twitter roses are red
violets are blue it's great being free
outside the EU Happy Valentine's Day wow
yeah I like it exactly
talking of embarrassing he didn't warn
me he was going to do that by the way
otherwise I'd have stopped him that is
so cheesy talky of embarrassing we did
come especially early this evening in
order to open the multiple cards and
roses that we thought peers would have
but but it turns out there were sorry
Pez there were no Bunches of flowers
absolutely niente so so um is it fair to
say that you're not a fan of Valentine's
Day and you don't celebrate it I
certainly don't celebrate red dress I
certainly don't accept yes I know by
accident I certainly don't celebrate
Valentine's Day but I'm always pleased
for British business and if people want
to go and spend their money on rot
that's fine what did you get Paula
um
oh still waiting it sounds like yeah are
you scary exactly no no doubt it will be
there waiting for me when I get home
I've been in Luton all day why is he's
coming in this studio
I'm sure
you say you don't celebrate Valentine's
Day but do you celebrate love
no
and I think that's the end of this year
right
and come on and the great thing is you
you're happy that actually in terms of
business British corporations growing
that's going well what they want to do
if they want to celebrate what is it you
said celebrate love if they want to
celebrate Valentine's Day if they want
to celebrate anything at all and they
want to go out and they want to spend
their money that's good for the economy
but so bang on but you're not you're not
joining in again it's broadening though
isn't it Valentine's Day I think it's
getting bigger and it's not just about
romantic love now you can get cards for
all sorts exactly yeah you know it's
good it's good to you know it's about
children it's about your gal Valentine's
Day did your children remind a partner
to do the Valentine's Day
you can get belated over a week and have
sort of you know you can have another
one tomorrow well we can have a later
dinner I mean more flowers are coming my
way hopefully
and I do think like on a serious note I
do think it's really important to
celebrate love I don't I'm not surprised
that the figure has increased since last
year remember we were just coming out it
was the last horrid lockdown we've got
to be able to express yourself
we're feeling all sweet lovely whatever
you're doing make sure it's uncensored
good night good night
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers more